le
[Musique]
on
le tonnerre en rond aucun débordement
s'ils surviennent nous y répondre
la ville de biarritz ne doit connaître
durant ce sommet aucun trouble
susceptibles de nuire au travail de ce
corps et internationaux
[Musique]
les restrictions sur les manifestations
ça c'est que ce serait une première dans
le cadre des sommets du g7 et ce serait
un grave précédent tour
pour les libertés publiques
[Musique]
il
300 gardes à vues par jour ce serait
déjà très important on n'a même pas vu
pendant les jeunes évidemment la
tentation de l'état s'est fait en sorte
m sorte de chapeau sion surtout ce qui
va se passer et que rien ne sorte mais
effectivement on sera là pour faire en
sorte que la liberté soit toujours
l'impact est encore au minimum
[Musique]
nous comme on réagit c'est de dire que
le contre-sommet qu'on a souhaité
organiser se construit dans un consensus
d'action qui se veut non violent
pacifique mais néanmoins déterminée
[Musique]